everybody loves ice cream
even those who say they don't like ice
cream still my blessing
we use ice cream as a way to support our
community my name is Michael Mikey Cole
and I own Mike he likes an X I did not
always sell ice cream I was born in the
Lower East Side of New York City's
Village two blocks from the shop while
selling drugs at one point I hit up
getting caught and I'm going to jail for
six months a few years ago my mother got
sick I promise to her that I wouldn't be
locked up anymore I'd do the wrong
things ice cream was something that just
came into my life at a time when I
didn't really know what I was kind of
doing this is pop culture inspired ice
cream we attract and kill truffle
shuffle Ice Ice Baby employee may
condition southern hospitality and we
have smooth operators a bunch of famous
people have come by here futures our fan
joaquim know as a fan hillary clinton's
a fan we have a lot of other fans up
I still live two blocks from the store
part of our job is to still be heavily
in the community and so kids come in
here with a a on their report card we
give them a free scoop of ice cream it's
to show them that we are the same as
them so I'm just a little older but I'm
still the same child at heart and if you
can find something that you like and
you're passionate about
go forth - just go for it you know don't
do not go for your aims go for every
last one that you have